Новина про збільшення квот безмитного експорту до ЄС для низки українських продуктів порадувала
українських аграріїв, але стурбувала частину українських споживачів.
Вони побоюються, що нагода продати більше продуктів до Європи призведе до їх дефіциту на Батьківщині, а отже - до подорожчання.
Насправді з великого переліку продуктів, якого добивалася українська сторона, ЄС поки що збільшив тарифні квоти лише на вісім позицій.
Йдеться про мед, оброблені томати, виноградний сік та низку зернових.
Для деяких продуктів обсяг безмитного експорту збільшили у два - два з половиною рази.
Так, з першого вересня українські підприєці зможуть без сплати європейських мит завозити до країн ЄС
на 650 тисяч тонн кукурудзи і на 350 тисяч ячменю більше.  Більше також можна, але вже - з митом.
Та якщо порівняти ці преференції з загальним обсягом експорту українських продуктів в різні
країни світу, то нові європейські квоти здаються мізерними. Наприклад, торік з понад 66 мільйонів
тонн врожаю зернових Україна експортувала до країн Азії, ЄС та Африки понад 44 мільйони тонн.
І близько двадцяти мільйонів тонн зернових традиційно пішли на потреби  самих українців.
На цьому тлі додаткові безмитні квоти у кілька сот тисяч тонн зернових є вкрай невеликими, і жодним чином на внутрішній ринок не впливають.
Так само і з медом. Щороку Україна експортує поза тарифними квотами близько 30-40 тисяч тонн меду.
Додаткова безмитна квота на три тисячі тонн меду картину не змінює. У Мінаграрполітиці визнають:
додаткові квоти від ЄС мають радше політичний ефект, ніж економічний. Це рішення Брюссель
ухвалив як жест своєї підтримки Україні на тлі економічної війни з боку Росії. Окрім того уряд
зобов'язаний моніторити баланс продуктів на внутрішньому ринку. Україна традиційно
виробляє набагато більше продуктів ніж споживає, ствреджують експерти.
Нові експортні квоти в ЄС не зможуть вплинути на внутрішній український ринок. Їхнє зростання
незначне, і вони не потягнуть за собою ані дефіцит продуктів, ані зростання цін на продукти в Україні.